quand mon père est venu de l'italie à
1934 dans la petite italie à montréal
nicolas di pietro prend une marche avec
ses souvenirs pas condamner déjà même
parce que ils ont l'apparence italienne
signer vos lusine de souliers la joconde
appartenait à sa famille et elle chaud
c'est la royauté britannique
mais elle a été confisquée par le
gouvernement fédéral à l'aube de la
seconde guerre mondiale le 10 juin 1940
le canada déclare la guerre à l'italie
de benito mussolini
ottawa ordonne alors l'arrestation des
canadiens d'origine italienne de crainte
qu'ils ne soient des saboteurs ou des
espions
pour le père et l'oncle donné que
dipietro
c'est un long calvaire qui commence une
série d'autobus et d'un père dit warren
se sont en ligne ici la grc rendant la
bâtisse et anos d'arrêter toute
traduction du nom était un peu effrayé
qu'on veut c'est un 10ème et âme avez
vous des éléments donnent déjà dit
penser voyez toute cette foule là et il
faisait dire au président a nié qu'il
vient de se faire arrêter à cause de la
gare aux devises les fusillés thot je me
suis dit quel paris ont dû avoir
près de 600 italo canadiens sont
arrachés à leurs familles et emprisonnés
dans des camps d'internement à
kananaskis petawawa ou frédéric denis a
fait ceci célèbre photo de mon grand
père lorsqu'il était où aucun
d'internement en tout et partout où il
est passé environ deux ans
un sujet tabou dans la famille james a
grandi sans connaître cette histoire
sa mère a gardé le secret presque toute
sa vie même quand il lui a annoncé qu'il
voulait devenir agent de la grc
c'est clair il il avait une honte je
suis certain qu'ils avaient une colère
également mais l'histoire permet parfois
de boucler la boucle en 2012 il devient
responsable de la sécurité nationale à
la grc et il a une pensée pour son grand
père si j'étais vivant à l'époque
j'aurais occuper le poste qu'elle était
responsable de cette opération inclut l
arrestation de mon grand père dé vie
chamboulée des années voler une
injustice qu'ottawa veut corriger avec
des excuses officielles
un geste qui n'est pas sans susciter la
controverse le fascisme existait au
canada dans les communauté
italo-canadienne je crois que le
gouvernement veut présenter des excuses
tout court sans faire la distinction
entre ce qui est un coupable et ce qui
ne l'était pas je réponde en tant que
ministre la justice
en regardant en arrière il n'y avait pas
des accusations criminelles
il y avait aucune conviction pour le
premier ministre de la justice d'origine
italienne
le moment est plus que symbolique
personnellement pour moi aussi c'est
ce sera ce sera très émouvant et je vais
essayer de garder garder les yeux les
yeux les yeux secs
c'est une forme de rédemption une forme
de justice soulagés rien vu la fin de
chars place et l'on est triste un bon
teintée de regrets pour son père mort il
ya quatre ans sur l'été je crois
chez qui il aurait vu se faire
pour les victimes aujourd'hui disparu
l'injustice est impossible à réparer
[Musique]